one of our favorite ways to connect is
with healthy competition
and if you know me you know i love to
play and win games
because it's just what i do um so every
once in a while we need another host to
step in
i can't play and host luckily we've said
our prayers and know a guy in a rather
high position
he's the biggest star in the galaxy you
know his work well because well it's all
around you
voice of god are you there it's me kelly
i am
hello kelly nice to see you again
it's so awesome every time you're on the
show i love you so much
um so i know you know jason drew
obviously you know all of your children
of course i do hello my son you know i
have to tell you
i just love your work as a little kitty
cat
oh thank you thank you god
all right well voice of god you have
been on the show a couple times now in
season one
so what about connection is important to
you well take it from me
connecting with other people in this
world is everything and i should know
because i made it i mean
all right well voice of god will you
help us with the game
you bet i will kelly now this game here
is called dear god
what's the connection
okay now the rules are i will give the
names of two famous people
now it's your job to tell me what
connects the two so for example if i
said
tim allen and tom hanks you would say or
wait
okay well that's right we're not playing
yet kelly but i know i got i get very
excited god you know this yes you won
the uh the tryout round now here we go
whoever raises their hand first will be
called on to guests
now a correct guest will get a point but
an
incorrect guess will send you straight
to you nowhere
damn no i'm just playing i'm just
playing
now if you guess wrong the other person
gets to guess
most points wins okay now how does that
sound it sounds great
all right let's get started here is your
first connection
will smith and tyra banks
oh i got nothing me neither wait wait
wait wait wait wait
what will smith and tyra okay kelly
raise their hand what you got
was she on first prince of bel air that
is correct
yes oh i love that show
i love that show too how did i miss that
i didn't i didn't remember that i just
kind of assumed maybe it was that i was
like yeah
tyler banks was in first prince i feel
like everybody that show was so big
i mean god would know you know
apparently you didn't love it enough
because you got zero points and kelly
has
one let's tighten that up okay now don't
tighten up you got a chance to come back
here is your next connection
okay meryl streep and denzel
washington uh
oh no no no no no i was gonna say um oh
it's the one with her son
it's not the manchurian candidate is it
it is the manchurian
that that gets very shakespeare y'all
she and her son in that movie
it's like kind of weird i was like kind
of like no i didn't see that one
oh it was a wonderful film and i got to
tell you kelly got two points so far
jason
jason i'm killing you oh man i'm falling
behind
behind you okay all right your next
connection
is amelia clark and peter dinklage
i got it you go jason game of thrones
game of thrones
it is coming back
you now on the board you got one point
kelly got two she's in the lead
here is our next connection everybody
get ready hang on tight
because your next connection is taylor
swift and
dame judy dench oh got it okay jason
did you say it yep cats that's it i just
wanted to hear you say it again it's
cats oh my god
now we got ourselves a tie game here
here is your next
connection okay tupac shakur
and janet jackson oh got it jason derulo
uh uh uh poetic justices
oh my god i haven't seen it
and this this lead is poetic jason with
three points
and kelly has two come on girl i know
you can well i know i was gonna come
back now
here it is your next connection joe
exotic
and carol best oh got it oh oh
i think kelly raised her hand i think i
saw it i think
yep you said it tiger king yes
crazy show okay
now listen y'all we have a tie game here
and we're about to give you your final
connection so this
is for the game okay okay don't let me
down
here you go your final connection is
sasha baron cohen
and will ferrell oh kelly tell the [ __ ]
nice
nah should i watch it oh my god it is
so funny oh i gotta go check it out
that's kind of i feel not fair because i
saw that and you didn't
but i didn't see i haven't seen poetic
justice in forever
yeah that was a good one that was a good
one i caught up though
i gotta be honest with you i'm sweating
in my spacesuit man
i totally thought i was losing that well
thank you so much voice of god
thank you as always it's a pleasure and
jason
pleasure to talk to you my son you're
not quite safe out there all right and
it's always nice to see you again yeah i
gotta go take care of some things i'm
very busy as you can imagine
take care i guess you
are um thank you so much jason i always
love having you on and good luck
like i i totally understand about
just getting away from something and
having a fresh start like especially in
your career and that's really cool and
i'm really excited for you
um everybody don't don't forget to check
out jason single take you dancing
it's awesome
you